Well, let's talk about the halftime show,
because for people who are not football aficionados
that's what is also so extraordinary about this day
is there is something for everyone.
(audience clapping)
Who lives.
I love music, I love advertising, this is my fantasy day.
Aside from the love of football
'90s hip hop, literally the kings and queens.
(audience clapping)
It's gonna be huge.
CNN reports the trailer alone is epic,
it stars Eminem, Snoop, Mary J. Blige and Kendrick
all receiving a call from Dr. Dre
to unite at SoFi stadium in Inglewood.
And it ends with this incredible dream team
walking towards this stadium with "California love"
playing in the background.
A true ode to Tupac and West Coast rap.
This is the soundtrack of my life.
You've got everything.
I mean, you know, Cari, thoughts?
(audience clapping)
Listen, you took the words right out, this is my music.
I grew up on this,
Snoop Dog represents so much of what West Coast rap is
from its genesis really, truly till it became mainstream.
And it's almost as he has called himself, the Dog Father.
So it only makes sense that he and Dre have teamed up
for this Super Bowl, for this special moment.
Can't wait for that.
And you know, we're excited for the halftime show
for the Super Bowl, but let's face it,
what we all really want everybody is the Puppy Bowl,
the Puppy Bowl.
(audience cheering)
And "People" reports that teams have celeb coaches this year
for the Puppy Bowl.
Martha Stewart is coaching team Ruff
and Snoop dog himself is coaching team Fluff.
He's all over this Super Bowl.
And this year they have 115 puppies,
all up for adoption.
And guess what everybody?
We're gonna meet some of those puppies, they're right here
on our show.
They're here.
We've been holding them.
Oh my God, I got so many kisses just like minutes ago.
I've been like full blown make up,
puppy breath situation, nose to nose, one bit my chin.
I'm so in.
Do you know what you call a wide receiver
in the Puppy Bowl?
A golden retriever.
(all laughing)
All right, finally, if your favorite part
of Super Bowl Sundays is the commercials, guess what?
There is no shame in that game.
And we've got a sneak peek because this year
30 new advertisers are in the mix.
The prices are through the roof,
30 second slots went for 7 million dollars.
What? For 30 seconds?
I'm like, where does that money go?
It's ridiculous.
So here's one with Eugene Levy for Nissan.
And they transformed him into a hardcore action star
for this ad alongside real life action star Dave Bautista.
Watch this ad.
Eugene Levy?
(car tires screeching)
Eugene.
(helicopter blades whirring)
Where is he?
Where are you?
I'll be there in two seconds.
(car engine roaring)
(car tires screeching)
Well, cock-a-doodle-do.
(audience clapping)
That's just a little glimmer.
A tease.
A morsal of so much more to come.
Yeah, and you know next, we love it when people
who've been out of the spotlight for a minute
make a splash when they return on Super Bowl Sunday.
Hmm, I love that.
And guess who's back?
We haven't seen her, we haven't seen her,
but we'll see her on Sunday. It's Lindsay Lohan.
Take a look at this.
She's sleeping better than ever
(Lindsay snoring)
which the paparazzi aren't thrilled about.
I miss Lindsay.
She's even more productive,
trading DUIs for DIY.
The verdict is?
Gorgeous.
Maybe it's not what's gotten into Lindsay
it's what Lindsay's gotten into.
Hey William.
(audience clapping)
Welcome back, I love seeing her
I love her.
It's fun, it's so fun.
I'm so into this.
That's the thing about Super Bowl Commercials
it's like they revive careers,
you never know what you're gonna get.
It's everybody's talking about it the next day.
This is so fun.
(upbeat music)